[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the great nicknames in nba
history
he is uh 3d dennis scott one of the
great deep shooters in nba history
part of turner's sports nba analyst who
uh
who gave you that nickname 3d uh
down in orlando paul porter pa announcer
uh we're playing against the san antonio
spurs in the preseason game i came down
here to three in the corner
he said great scott i said well that's
what they called me at georgia tech
then i came down again and hit another
three and he said
dennis scott and then i made three
threes and i think in a minute and a
half he goes wait a minute
3d and i kind of looked over and i said
i
like that the rest is history but when
you miss
those shots in a game did you ever get
somebody to say oh yeah
3d of course you hit a
you get that from a few fans on the road
and you love it
but but but then you've been knowing me
a long time all of us great shoes have a
mindset if you miss two or three
we always believe the next one's going
in all right let's uh look at some of
this action here how much pressure is on
kevin durant now
given kyrie's availability and no james
harden
i don't know if it's pressure i don't
know if it's desperation
because we all know now if you're not
healthy in the playoffs
you don't have your best players it's
hard to beat people
and durant we know how he wears his
emotions on his sleeve
so he's going to try to do everything
possible to try to carry this team
which i think he needs to take a step
back and empower his teammates around
him
with leadership and say hey guys i'm not
going to try to get 60
yes maybe 40 but i need to get 10 15
assists like james harden does
get you guys involved let's play good
team defense and maybe we can hold on to
kyrie
or james hard to get healthy what do you
think of the bucks defensive strategy
are they going over the top with their
physicality here
no they're not you have to take
offensive players
out of their comfort zone we know kyrie
is a great player we know
james harden's a great player we know
kd's one of the best scores we ever see
it
but you have to be physical with them
and take them out of their comfort zone
and take them and make them do things
they're not used to kevin durant is not
used to a guy named pj tucker just
all in his face he's smaller but he's
stronger
and that's the physicality you're
talking about dan how do they let kevin
durant's bodyguard
on the court uh
i think the whole situation with the
fans personal security
they're not on the same page then i
don't mind players having extra security
they deserve it i don't mind arenas
beefing up extra security for the
playoffs
but we all have to be on the same page
you know who was who
come to find out some people didn't know
that that was the red security was that
james harden security
we didn't know who it was knows the guy
that was dressed up real big
trying to do the right thing but he
didn't i'm glad he didn't go overboard
did you ever have an incident like that
where somebody's on the floor
and you don't know who it is and why
they're on the floor
oh it was one time in phoenix because
you know obviously playing with shaq
everywhere we went something crazy would
happen and then just you know this guy
around the
shag shack i love you and of course
security said
get out of here
shaq was cr the stories i hear about
shaq
young shaq at practice yes like he would
he would run out with just his shoes on
is that
is that true just his shoes in his
birthday suit
[Laughter]
you're not going to take a charge from
him no you're like
oh what a goofball um should would you
have tossed
the joker i would have not tossed the
joker
i understand the rules i understand what
adam silver
and the brain trust is trying to do is
to keep the game calm
but we know that joker was not trying to
aim for cam
face we know he was trying to do a hard
foul if he gets the ball against the
steal we're
we're yelling oh my god great steal by
the joker he's trying to get back in the
ball game
it's an unfortunate situation i don't
want fans to put a
you know a smear over his mvp season of
one little small incident that it wasn't
that serious in my opinion
yeah i think it was how it looked though
dennis
and he was frustrated you got his coach
who's calling out his own team
saying they quit and i think it's
probably the joker saying let me
let me try to make something happen my
point is you're the mvp
you can't be in a position to all of a
sudden have a hard foul on somebody
you can't risk that and that's my
problem with it
and would i have tossed him no but he
put himself in a position
where he got tossed and i blamed him for
that
yeah i think that's a great learning
experience for him now he's turning that
corner to be a true superstar
because the last couple years so many
people didn't want to give him his flow
his flowers as we say or excuse me his
roses as they say while he's live but
he's proven he's a true superstar your
true mvp
he'll learn from his incident and move
on and still be a great player
if you watch him how about this if you
were just going to explain why the joker
is so effective
and nobody and somebody didn't see him
how would you explain what he does
because he can't jump he's not quick
he's strong he's got great eyes
great hands but how do you explain
somebody who does what he does but there
i said
even know me a long time you know back
in the day when you come to our game
just like now music right everyone
listen to music you get hyped up
when i tell people when you're watching
the joker turn the music down
because the music is low for him it's
between the ears
he understands where he wants to get on
the floor he knows the offense
he knows all four players who are on the
floor
where they like the ball where they want
to cut and where they need the ball
so the defense is oh you're gonna
pressure up on me i'll take my time
use my body use my methodical dribble
and let my players cut and if you make a
mistake on defense i'll find it
and that's the best way to explain it
because to your point he's not living on
the rim
he's not sprinting down the court but
the shots go in
he makes smart passes and he's always in
the right spot on defense to help his
teammates
he's dennis scott turner's sports nba
analyst the coverage continues tonight
on tnt sixers hawks
and then it'll be jazz in the clippers
you know what to expect out of the
clippers dennis
no i don't because i was on that series
with the mavericks and i saw what luca
doncic was doing to
the clipper so i was a little nervous
for them and i was saying to myself
if the dallas mavericks front office
would have made a few better
moves they'd be in the second round they
needed another shooter or two to make a
few more shots and the clippers will be
on vacation
on the flip side of that ty lue because
we know he didn't panic
he went to luke canard and we all was
like look canard lou
what are you doing he's not gonna help
you oh wait a minute three
three three three energy the next thing
you know they advanced
so with that being said i agree with you
earlier before i came on
i don't know if reggie jackson can
continue to make shots because he is
shooting the blood out of the basketball
very happy for him
if he can continue that along with
playoff p
not pandemic peak then i think clipper
nation could be excited possibly going
forward
you have the 76ers in the hawks and with
you know joel embiid is you know going
to be
he's going to be limited a little bit uh
although it hadn't really shown that
much but
um that that mentality that trey young
has
you know you're not supposed to have
that at this age but he
he's not afraid no damn
i just love this generation very similar
to devin booker
where we're saying that oh you got to
get in the playoffs you got to lose
around
or you got to be like we were in orlando
you got to get swept your first time you
go to the playoffs
these guys said no we don't believe in
that narrative i want to win now
and the front office in atlanta in my
opinion have done a better
job putting better players around trae
young
versus dallas with luca and that's why
you see the hawks soaring
sharing the basketball like donovan's
shooting threes and telling the crowd
[ __ ] almost picking his nose all that
fun stuff
the hawks have had this much fun even
when they won the 60
game a season they're having more fun
now
back when they had 60 games i mentioned
this earlier about anthony davis
anthony davis has to reinvest in his
body the way lebron has because i don't
think anthony davis came into
this season in shape and it caught up to
him
um do you see a correlation between
he's sort of always banged up and i mean
at this age you're not supposed to be
as banged up as he is so what would you
do
i would take a page right out of your
your you know locker mate right there
with lebron like you said i think i'm
brian spent 1.5 million dollars a year
between the nutritionists and and
acupuncture
and the training so yes you have to do
that at this point in your career and
you may give them a pass lebron miami or
even dinner for a certain extent because
all those guys are in the bubble
deep into last season they had to come
right back but
bigger picture to your narrative no a.d
they brought you there for a reason
you're trying to extend lebron's career
a couple extra years
you have to be top-notch explain to me
chris paul um
special um as charles likes to say and
most people say one of the best leaders
that ever put on a pair of tennis shoes
and i'm just happy for him that this
point in his career
that he's staying healthy last night i
must admit we're all sitting here saying
monty you're up eight or nine don't you
want to get him out the game before he
bumps a pinky toe or pinky finger or
something
but to chris paul's credit he's like no
leave me in the game i want to make sure
we win because i get a whole week off
to continue all the treatment i've been
doing through this play-offs to keep my
body right
but he's been on multiple teams here so
when he says after the game hey
people thought i was washed you know a
year ago
well yeah i mean as great as he
is and he deserved to be a top three mvp
candidate
he hasn't won and then you have michael
malone the nuggets head coach who says
he's arguably the best
point guard of all time and i went
michael
did you ever see magic i mean there's no
argument here
right right no i agree with you i i
think michael malone
uh throughout the playoffs has admitted
that sometimes his emotions gets the
best of him
after games through his press
conferences so we both know michael
malone a long time i think he'd wake up
in the morning over a couple of coffees
okay guys i'll look at my feelings we
know magic's still the best point guard
to ever live
but okay is is chris paul better than
russell westbrook
on the all-time list uh as a player
yes stat numbers no
because we've seen chris paul go to
multiple teams and make the team
better and i think that's where the
minutia kind of confuses people
are we talking about explosive russell
westbrook are we talking about better
athletes
russell westbrook are we talking about
obviously the most triple doubles in our
in our era russell westbrook
but we're talking about what what chris
paul did in okc
with that young team and made them
better those are the things i think most
of us would give chris paul to nod as
the
overall better point guard numbers
russell westbrook
point guard chris paul better than john
stockton
oh i still i still got john stockton i
mean when you look at that assist record
that alone i don't think one of the few
records in sports i don't think
nobody again even though what russell's
doing i don't think nobody get
cerebral the screen setting the
leadership
and i think then what we're all trying
to figure out is how come guys like john
stockton the karma loans of the world
with all the great play
they don't have a ring yeah and i think
that's to this question where we're
going
if chris paul gets a ring as we know in
the media
his narrative will change a whole lot
1995 playoffs you were with orlando you
beat the bulls
did you think you'd won the championship
by beating the bulls because you went on
or you guys lost to the rockets but
did did that kind of like we beat jordan
and now we got the rockets and you
remember that same year then we had game
seven at home
against the indiana pacers who had just
swept us the year before
so we had two like like roller coasters
like yes we just beat mike
oh my goodness we just beat reggie yes
oh we got the rockets oh we beat them
both times in the regular season we
should be okay we're young we're
zurich oh snacks max max max
but you can say you beat the bulls in
the playoffs there dennis
and when the uh you know the jordan
series came out
everyone's texting oh man you don't want
to ever beat the bulls back today
yeah we got our ass
a few weeks later how mad was jordan
after
orlando beat the bulls he was hot
i mean it was it was well known you know
when nick anderson you know made the
comment you know 45 not quite like 23
like no
no no
but we knew mike was going to come back
and change his body right after coming
back from baseball we knew that we know
what type of competitor he was and then
you got swept by the bulls the next year
the very next year having a great year i
think we're second in the east
and we're like oh oh he's got that look
in his eye
[Laughter]
we've seen that look we've we've seen
yes yeah yeah we've seen it
there's a different look and i think
kobe had it
and i think watching devin booker and a
little exchange with him and lebron
with with with the uh jersey and lebron
was honest
devin's different devin's ready devin is
not just happy to be here
he's not just happy to possibly get this
new max contract
he wants to win and be the next guy we
talk about
every day i was wondering about this
dennis
devin booker owns the last game worn
jersey of lebron james wearing number 23
because he's switching back
to six so this is can you imagine with
all of these prices for trading cards
and memorabilia
what is the last game worn lebron jersey
where he had number 23 going to be worth
10 years 15 years 20 years
if lebron stays healthy say lebron comes
back we know lebron's going to do
whatever to get his body right
and hopefully and i like because i know
rodriguez so i can go ahead and say this
out for you for our viewers pressure is
on rod lincoln
now you you let rondo go for dennis
schruter
it didn't work you let javel mcgee and
the white howard walk
you brought in montreal's herald and and
assault
it did not work lebron is not 21 anymore
as much as we love what he's doing his
age we know father tom is still
undefeated we just talked about a.d
taking care of his body roblinka has to
put the right
vets in the right shot makers around
both of these guys
otherwise laker nation is going to be in
trouble the next couple years
great to catch up with you as always
there dennis thanks for joining us
come on i got the phone call i said damn
that's just no problem baby i love my
guy
thank you buddy that's uh dennis scott
one of the few guests who's a better
shooter than me